Tyreek Hill's wife is the last Lady you
want to mess with well I mean besides
his mom if you remember this but tyre's
wife expects nothing but greatness from
Tyreek when he went down with an ankle
injury that Tyreek said he thought was
the end for his ankle he texted his wife
saying his ankle hurt and he'd
definitely be needing an ankle massage
later that night she responded saying
quote you'd better get your ass back in
that game dog and that clearly was not a
suggestion so Tyreek swallowed the pain
and got back on the field he said he
needed to bring the energy and bring
that spark they lost by one point which
sucks but I'm sure they would have lost
by a hell of a lot more if tyre's wife
didn't send that text